What do you feel about that business today
versus what it was in your day?
That's a brilliant question because.
It- 20 years ago, if we were there when we
were on top and it was the Attitude Era and
it was me and Stone Cold and Undertaker and
all these other guys who were putting it
down every night.
It was tough, the role of a female wrestler
at that time in that business at that time
was hard, man. It was hard, you can imagine.
But the world, that world today is much more
inclusive, much more respectful, much more
really creating and delivering efforts to
make sure that all the females.
They're aware, they're aware, they're aware,
they're aware.
And I think, you know, sometimes it takes the
it takes the mirror being held up for you to
go, Oh, shIt, I had no idea that we were
that like, Oh f***, God damn.
Like we were. Okay, well, let's, let's,
let's, let's make sure that we fix this
incorrect. And I think to your point, you
know, when you talk about the women and the
the the the level of inclusion, it's huge.
It's massive. It's huge.
You know, Sasha is one person I talked to a
while ago and just her story and her
involvement and how.
What's that? What'd you look at me like?
That little twinkle in your eye.
That's a twinkle.
What are you talking about, Sasha?
I was like, Wow, What are.
You talking about?
I heard your voice change. No, but you just
said like that. No, I.
Said it just like this.
I love Sasha.
She's great. Yeah, that's how I said it.
No, no, not like that.
What the f*** are you doing? I'm just.
No, you. I'm just saying. What do you mean,
you? You have a great amount of admiration
for Sasha. Yeah, she's a badass.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Beautiful, gorgeous, badass.
I didn't say no, no, That's because.
But I know. What do you know?
I look deep into your eyes.
What are you talking. You admire all those
things? Yeah. About Sasha and women.
Yeah. Yes.
Okay. More.
All right.
You know, I was thinking about is when we
used to sit. We used to sit for our.
For our junkets.
And anyone who would come in, I'll just.
It's just bad.
It's bad if it were, by the way, or if it was
anybody of color.
Yes. I'd be like, Hey, come on, baby.
And he would be like, no, don't, don't,
don't do it like that. Would you come?
We all we got. Oh, my God.
God forbid any beautiful anyone beautiful
walk in. Oh, hey, Hey.
You know, am I your favorite?
Oh, my.
God. What do you got to be a jackass?